The Secret Life of Pets might technically
be considered a kids' film, but the story
is so much fun that it appeals to grown-ups
as well.
Of course, watching a movie as an adult isn't
the same experience as watching it as a kid.
Here are things that only adults notice in
The Secret Life of Pets.
There's no doubt that Katie loves Max, but
she's not exactly the most responsible pet
parent.
"We met a few years ago.
And boy lemme tell ya, we got along right
away.”
Early in the story, we can see her biking
with Max who is riding unsecured in a basket
attached to the front of her bike.
"It's me and Katie, Katie and me… us against
the world.”
When you want to ride a bike with your dog
in real life, they should always be safely
harnessed in the basket.
This will keep them secure so they don't bounce
out if you hit a bump in the road.
And speaking of unexpected circumstances,
Katie should obviously be wearing her helmet,
too.
"I know this'll take some getting used to.
But, but I think it's gonna be a great thing
in the long--"
Duke is a huge dog.
But he's also just an outgoing pupper who
just wants to make friends with his new roommate,
Max.
He excitedly greets his new canine pal, although
he isn't given the most welcome of greetings
in return.
"(Max growl) No Max, ok, it's gonna be alright
Duke.”
In real life, introducing two dogs to each
other for the first time doesn't always go
that smoothly.
According to the Animal Humane Society, it's
best to keep them leashed at first and allow
them to slowly get to know each other.
They also should not be left at home alone
together right away, at least not in the same
room.
Katie should have either put them in separate
rooms or crated them, which, at the very least,
would have prevented Max from creating a mess
in the apartment.
"Welcome to the underbelly brothers.
Home of the flushed pets"
The primary antagonists throughout the film
are the Flushed Pets, a motley crew of animals
that have been abandoned by their owners.
They make for a well-organized group of militant
animals who are understandably angry with
humans for how they've been treated — only
accepting Max and Duke after they claim to
have killed their owners.
"Death is comin’ to Brooklyn, and it's got
buck teeth and a cotton tail.”
The group is loosely modeled after the Black
Power movement of the 1960s and '70s, which
has drawn some criticism since the Flushed
Pets are portrayed as the movie's bad guys,
and their very real problems are used as comedic
relief.
Jason Johnson, a professor of political science
and political editor of The Root wrote that
the use of racial stereotypes in the film
is problematic and that they quote, "turn
black protest and death into a joke."
When Max and Duke go missing, their faithful
friends come to the rescue.
They band together, determined to sniff out
their missing pals and bring them home before
Katie even realizes they're gone.
They need some help, though, and one of the
animals they enlist is a predatory hawk who
lives on the roof of their apartment building.
"I can see for miles.
If you let me out, I'll find your friend.”
But in real life, the city has some pretty
strict laws governing what kind of pets residents
can keep, prohibiting them from owning wild
and illegal animals.
On the list of banned pets are not just hawks,
but also other predatory birds such as eagles,
falcons, vultures, and owls.
Like most dogs, Max and Duke love food.
When they enter a sausage factory in search
of a snack, they eat so much that they fall
into a food coma and doze off into a daydream
that's basically doggie heaven.
To kids, this scene is a feel good number
with a couple of cute pups.
Adults, though, will recognize that the song
the sausages are singing is from the musical
Grease.
The iconic number, "We Go Together," is one
that might not be too familiar to kids, but
is sure to strike a chord of nostalgia with
grown-ups.
Co-director, Chris Renaud told Entertainment
Weekly,
"It just felt like [the song] fit perfectly,
truly.
It's the kind of scene people either love
or think, what the heck was that?
I like to think the 'I love it' outweighs
the 'what the heck was that?'
crowd."
"I mean this may be the sausage talking, but
you're ok.
Right back atcha man.”
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.